do you realize you can extend your life
just by fixing your sleep if you're
getting less than five hours of sleep
your risk for dying goes up by like 12
so
the sleep is a very powerful predictor
of all cause mortality and i'm not just
talking about the amount of sleep i'm
talking about the quality of sleep so
let's talk about how to increase the
quality of your sleep there's three main
problems either you can't get to sleep
you can't stay asleep or you wake up too
early okay
now if you get up at two
that's
because your cortisol is too high i have
a separate video for that but this video
in general should help you
everything is controlled by this
extremely tiny
little structure in your brain okay it's
called the supra cosmotic nucleus so
that's something to say at a party to
sound intelligent but the
suprachiasmatic nucleus
is about one-fourth the size of one
millimeter squared but the size of this
little nerve bundle is extremely small
it's like a
fourth of
one millimeter okay it's just like
really really tiny you got two of them
and they're like a pair and they control
the clock in the body okay
they control the circadian rhythms of
the body
and it's their main hormone that helps
with this is called melatonin okay so
melatonin triggers
this whole process and the most powerful
controlling factor over this
this structure right here
is light okay
and dark
cycles
and so the real problem
with our sleep
is that we live
in an abundance of artificial light okay
so first of all our light is artificial
fluorescent lights
um and also we have too much light
i mean
light is 24 hours like if you live in
the city or in your house you can keep
the lights on and we pretty much have
the lights on all day as we're by our
computers right we go places there's the
lights on in these rooms and then of
course you might be watching tv with the
lights on and all that light inhibits
this melatonin okay so melatonin
is triggered by darkness
so
that's one thing you need to know but
there's another type of melatonin
that is outside
the little gland that makes melatonin
which is called the pineal and so
there's another source of melatonin
that's made by all your cells okay
that's outside the pineal gland and that
melatonin is triggered by
light but not any light
very specifically infrared light okay
it's a certain wavelength of light
and so you have this whole spectrum
of light starting over here with like
ultraviolet light and it goes to the
visible spectrum of light
and then we have infrared on the other
side
and it just so happens that the sun has
over 50 percent infrared
so it's really important to expose
yourself to sun
to get more infrared to build up your
melatonin
and melatonin has
a lot of other functions that go beyond
just sleeping
melatonin is the most powerful
antioxidant so it helps with a lot of
other things it gives you energy and it
helps protect you against diseases and
even cancer but also it helps you sleep
so
to improve your sleep let's just take a
look at what you need to do number one
if you want to reset your circadian
waves okay it's very important to expose
your eyes and your body to light in the
morning when you wake up this will
greatly start to give communication to
that little
nuclei to tell it to
work correctly okay so the best thing to
do is to get out in the morning when the
sun's coming up and expose your eyes
and body
to that light of course i'm not saying
to stare right into the sun but just be
out there for at least 30 minutes that's
the best thing you can do if that's not
an option you can get a bright light
okay it's called bright light therapy
and expose your eyes and your your body
to this bright light for about 30
minutes in the morning
okay so you might want to do that in the
winter time but even if it's a cloudy
day you're still going to get um some
good rays
and even in the woods if you're standing
in the woods you're still getting a
significant amount of infrared because
infrared
penetrates through the
canopy of the the leaves and the
branches and it comes right down and it
also penetrates through our bodies
through our clothes about a couple
inches so it can go right into our body
i'm talking specifically about infrared
that's why people that get more sun
exposure actually sleep better all we're
trying to do is align our bodies to
nature okay
you should wake up to sun and go to bed
when it gets dark right that's all we're
trying to do now in the p.m okay when
the sun's going down ideally
to
expose yourself to this sunset okay that
would be very very
therapeutic if you could do that or you
can actually expose yourself to a red
light right red light therapy which is
infrared but not necessarily right
before you go to bed
like at least two hours before you go to
bed or sometime in the day because it
can
generate a lot of melatonin that can
actually give you energy okay so
that might not be the best thing right
before bed
or
okay you can just expose yourself to sun
during the day
because like i said before over 50 of
the sun's rays
are infrared and so if you're getting a
good amount of sun you'll have a lot of
melatonin which is going to help you
sleep because that's going to recharge
melatonin
and the other thing is
towards the evening okay let's say seven
eight o'clock nine o'clock ten o'clock
don't be sitting in a room with your
lights on start turning the lights off
if you're watching tv
kind of just dim the lights in your room
or just have candles okay
or if you have a fireplace have that as
your light that'll give you a lot of
infrared
candle light
and
a campfire and your fireplace all give
off infrared it's that nice yellow
orange flame and you can feel infrared
by by heat now the second most powerful
stimulus for that little nucleus that
helps your circadian rhythms the
exercise consistent regular exercise
creates significant improvements in your
sleep cycles okay so that's number three
and number four keep your room cooler
because if you're sleeping in a hotter
environment
you will not be able to sleep as well so
i keep my temperature about 68.
number five magnesium is a really good
remedy there's a lot of remedies but
magnesium is really good to take before
you go to bed if you want
recommendations of a good one i'll put a
link down below but magnesium can help
relax the entire body relax the muscles
and it can actually allow you to drift
off into a really good sleep there's
other things like vitamin d
zinc and there's also stress reducing
herbs like ashwagandha there's a lot of
things but these five things are the
most important things to improve your
sleep and extend your life now if you
haven't seen my video a melatonin that
would be a very interesting one to watch
i put it up right here check it out